foreign
welcome everyone please be patient as I
begin the uh live stream or our LinkedIn
audience
which will take about 30 seconds to set
up
you live in a one-click world for
everything except this
all right
all right and Welcome to our LinkedIn
live stream audience as well as our
YouTube live stream audience and
everyone here live
on WebEx
my name is Stuart Creek I am a marketing
manager at simply learn I'm here with
professor sumiasen
more about him in a moment but this is a
live look at our cloud computing boot
camp from the Carlson School of
Management at the University of
Minnesota
we'll be talking today about cloud
computing
Dr sun will go over his views on the
field and then we'll talk about how the
boot camp helps you as the learner we'll
talk about some of the program outcomes
and Dr Fenn will also be talking about
the Carlson School of Management its
reputation and its value to you as a
learner so
I'll let Dr sen talk more about himself
but I will just mention that he is um
the McKnight presidential fellow at the
Carlson School of Management and
associate professor in the faculty of
information and design Sciences
and uh
a noted expert and researcher in
various aspects of digital systems
including cloud computing and welcome Dr
San thank you for being here
thank you Stuart welcome everyone it's a
pleasure to meet all of you
um and uh as Stuart mentioned I am a
professor of information and
institutions School my training is
primarily in engineering and computer
systems computer systems and networking
telecommunication networks and my
research interests are information
technology and business analytics in
data analytics and throughout this uh my
career I've been working with many
companies uh many of them who are
heavily using cloud computing that kind
of informed uh our view of the program
and today I'm going to present uh some
overview of the field as I see it from
talking to cios and uh and and give you
an update on the program and the
structure of the program so uh at
Carlson school one of the teaching
guiding principles in their teaching is
why before how that is to talk to
students about why they need to learn
about a particular field or a particular
topic before we talk about the house of
that area and what are the problems that
we can solve so keeping that a spirit in
mind I'm going to provide a quick
overview of why cloud computing is
important as a career field as well as
important for businesses
so why Cloud
the cloud computing as we probably all
know has immense potential in unlocking
value for businesses and in fact
McKinsey estimates that the cost Savings
in it and from creating a value-oriented
business use cases can unleash a one
trillion dollar of potential for Fortune
500 companies by the year 2030. and we
see this already many of the companies
that we know have been using cloud
computing very effectively uh over the
last few years for example moderna one
of the companies that I'm sure all of
you are familiar with given that we are
just emerging into a post covet World
hopefully and uh moderna is one of the
companies that created the MRNA based
based covid-19 vaccine and there uh see
CEO Stefan bansell had this vision of
using the latest Technologies in order
to provide a competitive advantage to
their company from the very beginning so
even before covid-19 modern I had always
been a very technology forward-looking
company and moderna's entire
mRNA research and development facility
is based in the cloud they run the uh
the web application that a proprietary
web application that they have called
the drug Design Studio that can analyze
a vast amount of data from different
trials for example the covid-19 trials
that they did and they use the Amazon
web services for data warehousing and to
integrate data streams from multiple
trials that are going on in parallel and
that helps them to quickly do the
analysis refine their design and
production cycle in order to improve
their products for example vaccines and
other drugs and as a result of using
cloud computing modern was able to
submit their first vaccine candidate to
NIH within 42 days of the initial
sequence and that is a really fast rate
at which a company was able to uh to
find that and then create a solution uh
just in about one and a half month and
that was primarily uh if not entirely
enabled by cloud computing uh previously
it wouldn't have been feasible to do
that much of computation of the genomic
sequences and
integrate results from trials and get
our product out within 42 days
and they have been using uh cloud
computing even for uh developing cancer
drugs they are again doing genetic
sequencing and comparing the results to
develop personalized Cancer drugs so
that is just in one example of a company
that we have been hearing about a lot in
recent times that is really using cloud
computing to capture market value from
that uh trillion dollar market now uh
very quickly I wanted to talk about the
different buckets of that value out of
the trillion dollar uh about the first
bucket is Rejuvenation of the existing
ID systems and processes and uh there
are different components to it for
example IIT cost optimization of the
application development maintenance and
the infrastructure itself reducing Risk
by creating more resilient processes and
ensuring uptime of those processes and
applications
um and uh digitization of the core
operations now most people would think
about these uh as the main cost Savers
like ID cost optimization improving
resiliency of your applications and
processes but notice that that is just
10 percent of the one trillion dollar uh
potential value that cloud computing has
businesses can uh get much more value
from using cloud computing to innovate
and moderna was a great example for that
uh many companies are already doing it
they are using Cloud for uh creating
growth uh based on uh analytics uh
integrating data from Internet of Things
enabling robotic process automation with
the help of cloud computing so
Innovation driven growth is one of the
big drivers for
companies where they can get a lot of
savings they can obviously actually
accelerate to their product development
and they can take advantage of the hyper
scalability of cloud in order to service
customer segments across geographies and
create more streamlined processes
globally so that's where a lot of
potential is of course there is a
potential from Rejuvenation of existing
processes by taking them to the cloud
cost optimization because improving the
resilience but there is a lot of value
from Innovation using analytics iot
automation that are heavily dependent on
cloud as the infrastructure and then
there is another bucket called the
Pioneer so the and and these are the
companies that would be our early
adopters of cloud computing in order to
perform experimentation with new
technologies or emerging Technologies
like AR VR blockchain 3D printing and
that value has not even been Quantified
because the business use cases of those
Technologies are yet to be realized
fully and so you can see that this is
more than a trillion dollar market and
that's why companies are very much
interested in uh adopting Cloud as well
as hiring talent in that space
so here are some quick examples of uh
use cases across different industry
verticals in retail we have
companies that are performing supply
chain optimization inventory
optimization in the cloud using
large-scale data sets that they're
collecting that helps them to minimize
waste in their supply chains they can
also use data from social media streams
in order to better predict which
products are going to succeed what their
customers want they're doing sentimental
analysis and again these are very large
scale data that have to be analyzed that
and requires computational power that
means scalability and that's why cloud
is a natural choice for these in
healthcare we saw an example of moderna
but there are also many other companies
more traditional hospitals Etc that are
using analytics machine learning natural
language processing on Text data on
electronic health records in order to
create better treatments and more
personal treatments for patients and
then optimizing the hospital processes
in high-tech industry we are seeing
increasing adoption of cloud for
enabling better customer support through
chat Bots creating more using the data
sets 8ml and AI in order to create
better customer loyalty programs and um
try to do media channel optimization in
other sectors too like in oil and gas we
are seeing use of cloud for doing
computation on the demand forecasting
supplies modeling Etc in banking a lot
of the banks are using data analytics
for digital advertising for better uh
personalized targeting of loans and
using
algorithms to inform their decisions
about different products and portfolio
optimization and all of these require
cloud computing as the Baseline
infrastructure on which these
Innovations are based
yeah and I'd like to just uh interject
one other aspect we live at a very
uh interesting time in history because
if this pandemic uh the covid-19
pandemic had happened just a few years
earlier there would not have been the
cloud infrastructure available worldwide
for us all to move to the work from home
model
so it's interesting that the existence
Cloud as a technology platform as a
method of interconnection uh enabled
that shift to happen
um I was at a
webinar a few days after the
work from home mandate was announced in
the United States and
um
the executive of the company that was
speaking said you know if they had told
us we needed to move to work from home
um we would have told them it would take
six months and 10 million dollars a
budget but when it actually happened we
were able to do it in three days at no
budget so that's the that's another
aspect of the pervasiveness of cloud
technology in all of our Lives exactly
the the hyperscalability the
availability of these resources uh in a
distributed environment across
geographers is obviously one of the main
reasons why the transition to uh the
virtual environment although may not
have been completely seamless was pretty
much seamless for most purposes from
tactical standpoint for most most
businesses thanks for clearing that
um so in terms of what businesses are
doing in order to take advantage of that
value that cloud computing can unlock
for them
there are three things like when I talk
to cios of different companies and and
Minneapolis has a lot of Fortune 500
companies located in it and so uh
they all understand that cloud computing
is a industry Catalyst for driving
Innovation for uh enabling digital
transformation because of the factors
that we already talked about like speed
agility hyperscalability
um and and as a result uh many companies
are now using uh public Cloud some are
using a hybrid cloud model for which
they have to do three things the first
is to start hiring a cloud literate
Workforce those that are trained in how
to use cloud computing resources
um then developing a first-hand
experience with the cloud and then adapt
adopting a technology forward mindset
and one thing I would mention is that
most of these Business Leaders they want
a Workforce or they want to hire Talent
who are not only trained in the
technical aspects of cloud computing but
also have that broader vision of how to
use cloud computing in order to bring
about Innovation within the company uh
it's the the biggest challenge I think
for companies is to find those right
people who can provide or can fill in
that that cap between
the technical aspects the technical
processes and the business processes
because when there are people in the
company that can bridge that Gap that's
when Innovation can happen at a very
fast pace and so uh most of the Business
Leaders would want us to train Workforce
that not only provides a very good
foundation for cloud computing from a
technical standpoint but also provides
the curriculum provides enough
understanding of the business aspects of
cloud computing the strategy aspects of
cloud computing so that companies can
execute a well-defined strategy uh that
has a uh that kind of creates value
across it and businesses together
and can Implement uh cloud ready
operating model and that's why uh we
think that curriculum should reflect
both the technical components but also
provide enough Vision about how these
technology can be used uh in order to
drive the corporate strategy uh in terms
of the hiring trend friends
there have been many reports here is one
uh from Robert Half uh hiring firm that
conducted some surveys about the hiring
Trends in 2022 and 48 of Technology
leaders expect their budget for cloud
computing projects will increase this
year and the rules where they are hiring
are in their teams are primarily in
Microsoft Azure and you can see sixty
percent of the respondents wanted to
hire uh folks that are trained in
Microsoft SEO to be Engineers developers
or Architects and Amazon web services
and of course there's also demand for
Google but Amazon and Microsoft Azure
are the primary leaders right now uh and
the kind of skill set that they want are
folks that are that are trained in cloud
computing in in managing cloud computing
resources security Cloud architecture
those are the top skills that are
required by IIT
in moving on to the next slide in terms
of the uh Trends in uh in in the job
postings uh here's a quick look at the
year-over-year growth for Azure demand
uh which has been growing uh 58 annually
since 2017. uh and compared to the cloud
skills in general and uh AWS is already
a market leader and uh Amazon uh
Microsoft Azure is following them very
closely they have been seeing
significant growth and we have probably
seen in the news uh that Microsoft was
able to get some very lucrative cloud
computing contracts that Amazon missed
out uh in the recent years and and both
of these cloud computing platforms I
have been posting a habit have been in
very much demand and that's why uh when
we look at LinkedIn posts for example
you see uh these are the uh these two um
uh Azure and uh Amazon web services are
the skills uh that we see uh very
frequently uh in in those postings in
terms so the kind of cloud computing
skills needed
and this need is not only uh in kind of
concentrated in a few uh segments it's
all across the industry verticals you
can see here the trend of uh cloud
computing Market size and how it is
growing in different industry verticals
uh between 2016 to now and projections
going forward and you can see whether it
is banking Finance or it and Telecom or
retail on manufacturing and Supply
chains uh energy companies Healthcare
media government and public sector all
of them are seeing uh remarkable growth
in terms of the use of cloud computing
as an infrastructure so the demand is
distributed across all industry
verticals
yeah I I would like to mention one
fascinating example it's fascinating to
me which is
um when the pandemic hit and people
started moving to non-contact ordering
from restaurants
um Wendy's the American hamburger chain
uh
was developing its mobile app for
ordering and one thing that they found
was that the data they collected from
mobile ordering behavior and from
ordering at the drive-through window
suddenly gave them insights that they
didn't realize that they had had into
the behavior of their customers so
um fascinating how in
an industry which we don't at all
associate with technology uh digital
technology at least
um has found that having the cloud
infrastructure to be able to collect the
consumer data from their customers and
then
being able to use that on the back end
to analyze and look for trends has
transformed their marketing transformed
their model of business
amazing ways so
when we talk about cloud computing it's
not just something or as Dr said the um
the technology sector it really is
transcendent across all business sectors
yeah thank you for hearing that too uh
Stuart and we are seeing that uh when we
are talking to companies in this area we
are seeing that exactly that across the
different companies like uh we have the
United Health Group that is using cloud
computing and in order to do analytics
and all the computation we have Mall of
America like closer to your example uh
which are heavily investing in
infrastructure uh in order to gather
data about users from the the Wi-Fi logs
and using Cloud as a way to analyze the
data and drive insights in order to
Define their marketing strategy leasing
strategy Etc so it cuts across every
industry vertical the use of cloud
computing and using that as the
infrastructure infrastructure to drive
Innovation and many of the Innovation is
coming through integration of data from
different sources from iot devices
um as well as from uh and then doing the
post processing of the data using data
analytics techniques machine learning AI
in order to drive those kind of derive
those kind of insights and then write
the business strategy based on that
so uh for a cloud computing career there
are certain skills that uh that are uh
needed and this boot camp is designed to
provide you with those skills for
example how to select uh Cloud vendors
and cloud service providers
how to do migration of applications uh
setting up apis uh configuration
management of those identity and access
management Cloud migration and
deployment in an effective way managing
databases again we talked about
large-scale data sets so how do you
manage databases in the cloud
and many other things like balancing the
workloads and making sure that the
system is resilient we talked about
hyperscalability one of the features of
cloud and so how to do auto scaling
performance testing and in in the boot
camp as you learn about these Concepts
you will also have the opportunity to
have Hands-On practice uh in a in a
sandbox environment in a lab environment
so that you're able to not only learn
about these things but also execute them
so so at this point what I'd like to do
is I'd like to launch a poll here you're
about to announce that yeah I was not
sure if you wanted to announce that go
ahead go ahead Let's Do It
um so we'd like to to know because
you're all here due to your interest in
cloud computing as a career what has
prevented you from enrolling in a
training program of this type of
pursuing this career to date so let me
launch this poll and if you're watching
on streaming
um
do put in we can use a b c and d for
these four uh into your comment section
I'll leave this open for about 30
seconds here
just to recap whether it's
being able to find a program that covers
all the skills that assuming just
mentioned or feeling that you need more
hands-on experience
or finding it difficult to just learn
from pre-recorded videos on your own
here we go
and by far the the greatest number of
people in the audience have said that
they don't feel like they give the
hands-on experience
practical exposure to be able to say to
an employer
um that they're confident in their cloud
computing skills and abilities and can
demonstrate those so let me
on and
I'm going to um
introduce this slide and then let some
of you resume but
um
the cloud computing bootcamp
from the University of Minnesota Carlson
school is a comprehensive collection
curriculum was an industry aligned path
so it's based on the needs of Industry
it has integrated case studies and
online projects that you do as you
mentioned in a sandbox environment so
that you're doing the work and not
simply just watching someone else do it
you're also building up a project
portfolio that you can take with you uh
you have online virtual classrooms where
instructors are able to interact with
you directly where you show up for live
classes uh every week and
then do your work in between the classes
on your own schedule whatever time you
have available in the rest of the week
24 7 so that you don't have to feel that
you are applied to a very rigid schedule
other than the
live classes themselves
so
um somebody did you have any other
observations about the overview of the
program here
no I think that this kind of uh provides
a very comprehensive view as I mentioned
like uh the program would uh is focused
on providing the technical Basics as
well as a Hands-On uh training and then
uh we have the master classes that we
are going to talk about later to provide
this connection between the technical
Concepts that you're learning and the
high level managerial and decision
making abilities that uh that that are
needed or are in demand from companies
thank you
so
so Stuart uh would you like to tease
this up or should I go there
uh
I'll go ahead with this one because it
mentions a job assist program which is
something that simply learned adds to
the value of the of the boot camp
um you do end up with the
certificate which is the attestation
that University of Minnesota Carlson
school
certifies that you have completed the
core courses of this curriculum you've
completed all the projects including the
Capstone project
that showed that you have a set of
skills that the boot camp
has provided you and then you also get
Alumni Association membership for
networking career value throughout your
career you'll be able to network with
other graduates of
similar Carlson school programs
but we also have a job assist program
from Simply learn which is part of the
services
and
I'll talk about that in a few minutes
some of you if you'd like to talk about
the school itself yeah sure so the
Carlson School of Management is uh is
one of the top uh schools uh in in
business education uh in the country in
Executive Education MDA programs we are
ranked 14th in uh in terms of the
ranking worldwide in business and
economics we are ranked 18th we have the
10th best undergraduate program among
the public schools so some of you are
probably familiar with the uh with the
cartoon school and the value that the
brand carries you know we have taught
faculties uh and in this uh program uh
for the master classes some of them will
be offered by me and some of them maybe
I'll be joined by other faculty and
including perhaps Professor Gupta uh
whose picture you can see in that small
in set over there who is the associate
dean of faculty and research at the
Carlson School and as I mentioned like
uh Carlson school is really based on the
philosophy of ensuring that we are
providing uh students with a holistic
understanding of both the technology and
how the technology can be used in order
to drive business value and we have many
other successful programs that that I
didn't highlight in terms of the ranking
like we are ranked top five in our
management information systems program
we are ranked again in top five in our
masters and business analytics program
which are very closely related to to
these uh to this particular boot camp
one thing I had mentioned uh for the
slide that uh Stuart showed earlier
um in as a part of this boot camp you
are going to receive a certificate and
while the Carlson school has partnered
with other
online platforms such as Coursera we do
not offer any certificate for those and
not one that is signed by our leadership
as you can see here this is a
partnership between the Carlson School
of Management and simply learn where the
certificate is issued in the name of the
Carlson school it carries the signature
of Professor Ravi Patna the associate
dean of Executive Education and so this
is uh special it is not something I have
been involved in a lot of online program
uh development online MBA and
specializations for Coursera this is
different uh from that perspective
because this carries our signature and
our support and you become a member of
cartoon School uh alumni which is about
55 000 strong
yeah just to give you a brief history uh
uh Carlson school is was established in
1919 and it has been a leader in
business we have uh management
information systems uh Department being
one of the oldest in the country uh we
uh we are more than 50 years old just in
Information Systems Department
um and we have uh 5 000 students 57 000
alumni about 10 percent of the
University of Minnesota alumni and uh in
terms of our faculty we have top-notch
faculty that uh that are recruited from
the top universities
um uh throughout the world uh and
particularly the top university of the
US 103 10-year antenna track faculty 39
full-time instruction adjunct faculty
and having the Carlson School logo and a
certificate to go along with your CV
will be recognized not only in the US
but worldwide
foreign
this is where I'd like to talk about the
career assist service that's part of the
boot camp
um
the boot camp is a six-month educational
program during the boot camp and for six
months afterward you receive access to
careers assist services
for Learners in the U.S
and this has several components it has
access to certain webinars and career
events that allow you to
take on additional
Education and Training at your pace
these are free one hour events that we
put on uh there's also the your
curriculum that includes real world
projects across industries that go into
your portfolio and then there's the
direct assist services from Talent Inc
which is the
partner company that provides for you
three things one is access to their job
portal which gives you exclusive early
access to a wide employer Network gives
you jobless things that are available
through this job portal uh earlier than
they are at other places but also it
allows you to apply for new jobs in a
discreet and confidential manner if you
are looking to change employers
discretion is always
important because you don't want your
current employer necessarily to be
monitoring your job search on
the other public job boards
um
quick anecdote when I started with
simply learn a few years ago
um very early on got a call asked if I
was being if I was looking for other
work at the same time and I had to
explain no I was not but I hadn't taken
my
rest of me down on places like Career
Builder or indeed or that type of thing
so
um be assured that confidentiality is
really important
um resume review and rewrite service is
also very important because today
before any human sees your resume
um automated systems will be looking it
over
um looking for keywords and other
patterns and filtering out resumes that
don't fit their algorithm so
it's important to work with resume
service that will
format your resume and help you choose
the right wording and
presentation that the automated Bots
will be able to
present you then on to the next level of
human evaluation and then that the human
evaluator will will be impressed with so
this is a really key part of the service
we also have one-on-one interview
preparation because once you get in
front of uh human evaluators during the
interviewing process you want to put
your best foot forward and so we offer
uh interview training sessions where you
live work with a interview prepare
prepare and practice questions practice
techniques get advice on your
presentation style so that you can be
the best you can be when you're in the
actual interview so this is a really
valuable aspect of the boot camp
as I mentioned webinars that we present
give you an ongoing support in terms of
keeping track of different topics in the
industry getting advice on how to get
the the most out of your job search
do we even have technology classes some
free master classes that we offer in
different technology subjects so this is
again another value and
the the boot camp itself includes
projects sampling of which are here
where you are given a problem that you
would encounter in the
real workplace
from the employer industrial line
problems that you then have to
solve as part of your streaming you get
to do the
actual work to solve the problem build
the solution
um present it and then it becomes part
of your portfolio so
this is a value a career value for the
uh
the boot camp so
um I'd like to mention the eligibility
and prerequisites
um
this particular boot camp does not
require a degree is that correct uh
come here
oh you're on mute here we go yeah
yeah so this is a very
um
I mean many of the the programs that we
work with uh Carlson School
in programs
require that you have a bachelor's
degree this one in particular does not
but you do need to be 18 years of age we
prefer to show some work experience but
it is not prerequisite and you don't
have a programming background
requirement so the upshot of this is
that the real single prerequisite is
that you 18 years of age can have
desire
the aptitude for exploring cloud
computing uh as a as a vocation
but with that I'm going to go to another
poll
this poll is
just to get a kind of a feeling for
who's here today
leave this open for about 20 seconds
just like to get an idea of
who's in our audience
and
I'll share with you the result
so it's kind of a bimodal distribution
you've got uh about a third of our
audience are folks with under two years
of work experience
but a third of our audience are people
with more than 10 years of work
experience the this is a
great
program for both categories it's not
something that requires you to have a
lot of experience to get into but if you
are experienced and want to Pivot into
the cloud computing world
this is a great way to do it
so I'm going to ask
my colleague Matthew David who is
one of our lead instructors executive
actually with Accenture
um
and he is going to share with you
the
way that this program
works in terms of your experience
online so
Matthew I hope you are there I am yeah
so yeah
very much for inviting me to join you
today
um
I would argue that cloud is probably the
most important skill set that anyone can
learn today it is it it is the New
Foundation skill set
so I'm excited to go through uh this
content so
um let me uh I'm just going to
take over just for a moment and share my
desktop
okay so I'm going to actually keep my
PowerPoint out of full screen mode while
I go through this just simply because
I'll be going between the PowerPoint and
um I want to actually step through what
the actual
um system looks like
um so let's make sure I get onto the
right slide here so we're going to go
through and I'm just going to explain
how you actually log into
the LMS system that we use and then I
have a couple of additional slides
around that and certainly you know
Stuart please jump in and and provide
additional content on anything that I
miss but I'm going to come in uh
initially as a regular student
um I'm actually registered for some
blockchain classes right now it's a an
area that I find fascinating so I want
you to see how I actually see this
experience so you come in and you log in
with your credentials and you'll get
your credentials either by through
registering with the site or somebody
will email those to you and oops
uh so uh when you come to the site um
the first thing that you can actually
see is a list of all the courses that
you are currently active in
um and you can split between inactive
and active courses
um and it'll give you a breakdown of the
course ID the the description of the the
course
um and then uh whether most importantly
whether or not you've actually completed
the actual uh course itself you can come
in and you can select any of these
courses
um and it'll give you a breakdown of the
actual materials that you need to You
Know cover you can actually download on
the ilt download there'll be uh will be
PowerPoints there'll be documents for
you but then also there'll be an ability
for you to be able to upload your course
materials so that you can actually have
your materials graded by the instructor
but then if you're working on materials
with other students there's a way for
you to be able to upload your materials
as well
um you'll be able to because this is
running your own time you can actually
see what are the the work that you
should be doing right now what is
upcoming and then again what's um
important which is completed you do need
to complete all of the materials to be
able to pass a course so it's important
for you to see that you have in the
completed section everything is showing
up as completed right now I don't have
anything showing up in that section
because I haven't started it yet
um
one of the things that I would add if we
come back to the course materials is
that some of your classes will have a
Capstone class section in them and the
focus of the Capstone is for you to be
able to
work with your your other students in
small groups and actually develop a a
project of a working solution and uh um
so if there is a Capstone there'll be
additional information on how to share
the Capstone information back with the
infrastructure so you can get graded
appropriately on that
um so and then there are also some
classes that will be live classes
um if you do have a live class you can
select the live class option on the menu
on the left hand side and it'll actually
bring up a calendar and give you a date
and time for when that client and live
class session happens those sessions are
important and try and make those as
really as much as you can because it is
a unique way for you to be able to
interact directly with the instructor as
well as uh the uh your the peers in your
class so suddenly please make time for
those
I'm going to pause there and Stu is
there uh anything that I else I should
be uh covering in the uh live demo of uh
the uh engage X experience
yeah one other thing uh is that because
this is a 24 7 platform you'll be
interacting with the learning management
system the engage X platform at times
when your instructor may be in fact
sleep
um so if if you're working on a project
during the week how do you get
support if you run into a blocker or a
question that that you need help with
are you there Matthew yeah are you
asking me and that question yeah I mean
can you show how uh how the learner can
ask for support from
peers from the support staff simply
learn and sure if I actually have that
access
here
um
so I'm going to ask a very dumb question
where would I actually find that Stuart
uh I can't really see your screen very
well so um but what happens is you have
a community uh
cab that allows you to ask questions
from your peer group
um you do have also the ability to
message your instructor with questions
and also to raise uh help
tickets if you have any technical issues
with the platform itself those things
are available to you so that the never
um without support
as you're doing your work throughout the
week
um I think I'm I'm just looking at
security the reason why I'm not saying
that is I'm not actively enrolled in one
of the classes right now so otherwise I
would be able to show that exactly
um the the other aspect that
the LMS has the ability to do your live
projects and the sandbox environment I'm
not because you're not enrolled in a
class I don't think you'll be able to
to show that as well but
when we talk about being able to do
these projects it's not something that
you have to download additional software
or do it in a separate platform all of
it is done within this platform and
you have the ability to run a virtual
machine on which you do any of the
exercises that require a configuration
of cloud resources
coding or
low code project development all of that
is within the platform itself so
uh anything else that you have
uh you'd like to add to that
Matthew
I think that really kind of covers
everything I think but really um goes
through our program do you
um do you want me to go through the next
couple slides or is this uh the section
you want to take
um I think we'll take it from here so
thank you very much thank you
allow me to switch over
I do want to be the presenter
okay
so as Matthew mentioned as you complete
each course you unlock it you get uh
credit for that course and you get to
unlock the next course in sequence so
that
let me go through this basic sequence of
the courses in the boot camp
other than the orientation which is just
basically learning how to use the
platform what the expectations are for
you you will go through uh beginning AWS
Cloud fundamentals
and then designing applications and
architectures in AWS
you'll then move on to the azure
fundamentals and learning how to
implement and administer the Azure
environment
you'll be able to develop infrastructure
Solutions on azure
and each of these is a several week
course again each one has to be
completed to unlock the next you reach
about the last few weeks of the program
you have a Capstone project Matthew
mentioned capstones on each of these
courses and then you have an overall
boot camp Capstone project which allows
or requires you in fact to take all of
the skills that you've learned through
the previous Court courses and turn them
into the solution to a business problem
a cloud-based business problem that you
then
develop a solution with the instructor
mentor and produce the final
project that you add to your portfolio
on a permanent basis that's a one of the
key things on which you will be
braided and your certificate will be
awarded along the way you have the
option to take the master classes from
Carlson School faculty sumia and his
colleagues as he mentioned who will be
offering those these are electives that
do not cost anything extra get to take
them per your interest in your schedule
so that's an added value in the program
and
I'm going to let samya address
yeah actual master classes
thank you Stuart uh so as I mentioned
earlier on like uh companies are looking
for the professionals that are trained
in the technical aspects which is what
uh Stuart was covering just before this
but also they want somebody who can
connect those Technologies and Technical
processes into the business process and
strategies and therefore the master
classes are designed to be complementary
to the to your learning of the technical
aspects of AWS and Azure and in these
master classes we're going to cover
topics such as uh just the fundamental
of cloud computing industry uh and uh
talking about the economics of cloud
computing uh choosing between vendors
and thinking about different aspects
related to it from login to the Opex
capex costs and making being able to
make those decisions based on numbers uh
then talking about governance and
policies in the cloud another master
class will be on The Cutting Edge or the
frontiers of technology in in terms of
where we see the industry going in terms
of cloud computing as well as Edge
Computing and the intersection between
the two and finally another masterclass
on cloud computing and its role in
designing digital transformation
strategy so these are meant to be
complementary and from a from the
business side to provide a much more
higher level understanding of the
technology and the capabilities of the
technology for a business
so in terms of the tools and platforms
that uh that you would be exposed to in
the code in the in the courses uh the
these uh courses will cover the topics
in
um uh as your fundamentals and AWS
fundamentals uh talking about the core
resources and storage Computing
um uh networking uh security of setting
up government governance policies uh for
the cloud infrastructure
um and also uh monitoring uh uh and and
deploying these resources managing
identities uh authentication solution
backup database application architecture
data recovery
um and uh account management uh and how
to create highly scalable uh
architecture that is so that the cloud
computing resources are available all
the applications are available and as a
part of this uh there are several
different tools that will be covered in
the boot camps here are just a couple of
them like Amazon ec2 cloud computing for
for computing platforms uh AWS Lambda is
a storage service from Amazon uh again
Microsoft Azure uh related
related services for resource management
resource manager
um
uh AWS
SNS services
and and so on so both for Microsoft
Azure and Amazon web services the
various companies related to uh storage
to networking to security governance
um and how to use uh these for
maintaining a scalable or designing a
scalable infrastructure is what you're
going to what is going to be covered in
the boot camps on the technical side of
things
then we'd have the Capstone projects
which we've mentioned a couple of times
and the importance of the the Capstone
project uh at the end of the the boot
camp again is that it becomes something
that you add to your personal portfolio
but it's also the way that
um
Carlson school and simply engage your uh
level of knowledge and skill in what
you've learned in the boot camp so
Capstone project is how you demonstrate
that you've absorbed
we are proficient in all of the skills
that we've provided to you during this
boot camp
it gives you your final grade and it
gives you the confidence then that you
can go into the workplace in industry
and
handle similar challenges from your
employer so this is a really valuable
aspect of how we structure the boot camp
all right a quick question
based on what you've heard today
uh are you interested
in enrolling in the spooking
I'll leave that open for just about
another 15 seconds or so
and we'll be sharing some more
information about how to enroll in just
a moment
all right
almost 85 percent of our audience
interested in enrolling in the boot camp
which makes this an opportune time
talk about how to do that the process is
very straightforward you submit your
application and ask us at
simplylearn.net
so you contact us there know you have
what you need to submit as materials
um
we'll do some basic uh review and
qualification for you to make sure that
you have what it takes to succeed in the
program
um and then we will offer you admission
at which point
you would
engage in your payment plan the Pro cost
of this program this is the us-based
program mainly intended for U.S students
the cost is eight thousand dollars
uh it can be financed at 704 dollars a
month
um God
the classes for the next cohort start on
December 2nd
so when you contact us we will be able
to share with you
a
bonus or a discount offer if you decide
to sign up for the December 2nd cohort
um as your
gift for being here today at the uh
preview we'll be able to offer you a 500
discount off of the course fees if you
decide to sign up for this next cohort
it's a limited time offer but to find
out you
you have to email us to ask us at
simplylearn.net
and
what I'll do is put into the chat window
that email address as well as
the
course page
link
that in right now
so you'll be able to click on those to
get to
this email and to the course page so at
this point
great time for questions and answers and
the time we have available for that I
will stop sharing the screen because you
don't need to look at the slide
but
pick some of the questions that you've
put in for
sumia one of them assuming is from emika
who
says that
there's a lot of hybrid Cloud
environment clients using Snowflake and
Azure and teradata and the AWS system
so
are these types of topics going to be
covered in the courses
working uh the how the cloud platforms
work with these other environments
so in terms of the uh content I think
the the main focus is on AWS and and uh
Azure so it's going to cover uh like
Azure blobs and AWS redshift
and they will talk about how to set up
the apis to connect to uh other uh
systems and other processes uh I'm I I
don't think that the in this particular
boot camp they would be going into that
much details about how to set it up in a
hybrid environment but I think the
instructor in the live classes can
provide some guidance along those lines
okay
emica also asks if the course includes
coupons for taking Azure or AWS
certifications from Amazon and from
Microsoft my understanding is that the
coupons themselves are not included
but that the courses should be able to
um
prepare you adequately to take those
examinations from from the vendors
so
um
C
do we have one other question from
Natasha who asked do you have to have
any degree or diploma in order to join
the course
we did we mentioned that in the the
prerequisites you do have to have a
secondary school diploma you have to
have a high school diploma
um you do not have to have a bachelor's
degree or or post-secondary school
degree
um
then
we have a question from Michael who asks
most employers require five to six years
of experience how do I get employed
without the required experience so if
you could send me a comment on
what are the experiences for people who
are
um
fresh out of school
they're fresh out of a program like this
so uh having a degree from a university
Affiliated degree is obviously useful in
terms of the credentials and as a part
of the program
as you saw in the boot camp there would
be Hands-On projects and Capstone that
can serve as a portfolio
and if you recall the slides that I
showed in terms of the hiring Trends we
are seeing uh for AWS and Amazon a year
over year growth in terms of those
skills being in demand for
um for by employers and so uh
it depends on uh I think the program
itself will and the degree itself will
provide a platform to launch a career in
that area and uh and uh it and with some
initial experience right it would have
the required uh exposure that you need
to go for this uh other jobs that you
may be more interested in with as you
have more and more experience it's all
true in any field uh that the jobs that
you can go for and the salaries
associated with your jobs would increase
so uh depending on the type of jobs you
are looking at uh entry-level jobs or a
little bit more like a mid level jobs uh
that I think the degree itself as well
as the training and the portfolio that
you would have uh from doing the
Capstone would be useful in providing
that platform to launch your career
and I think we have a couple more
questions uh from aviola one is how is
this coursework course outline different
from that of Simply learn I will address
that simply learn offers a number of
training programs including training
programs in cloud computing this
particular program is oriented towards a
US audience
which is a which is one of the reasons
why it's priced this way but the main
difference in this program from our
other programs Is the participation of
the Carlson School the fact that this is
a
program offered by University of
Minnesota Carlson School of Management
and the master classes that you receive
during this boot camp are things that
you will not receive in other simply
learn only
horses so the the value added in the
additional
insights into the industry
and the additional preparation for
becoming a contributor to the industry
are things that you can't get from our
standard simply learned skills training
program so that
so Samia said
it's one aspect of the boot camp program
is learning the skills
but the other
valuable aspect of this program that
makes it different is learning about why
those skills are important how the
skills are applied in the industry and
where the the future of the industry
will take you
um so that you can guide your career
in that path that you they will take you
upwards into more responsibility and
greater salary the that's
complete main difference between this
and the simply learn only persons if you
are uh
outside of the United States we have
different programs available
um and you can check those out on our
website go to the same link that I put
in and if you do a little bit of
browsing around our website you'll find
other programs suitable to you for for
non-us Learners this particular program
is
extremely valuable
well worth it for U.S Learners and the
other question
that aviola had was people not resident
in the United States or people who are
in the third third world countries for
example Africa that type of thing
um what are chances of getting
employment if you don't get a work visa
to work overseas
that's an interesting question you might
be able to address
come here
you're on mute I'm I'm not familiar with
what the current requirements of the
Visas are because they keep changing uh
this is something that we can get back
to you uh like I lead to refer this to
our universities Administration to and
staff who can provide you a correct
answer I don't know off the top of my
head what the visa requirements are
whether they
yeah and one one thing I can add though
is that in today's environment your
ability to work for an organization does
not always require you to be on site at
that organization so there are
a number of opportunities that people
have
from third world countries where they
can work remotely
or other organizations and those are
good opportunities to look into
um we do actually have
partners and and offices in other areas
including in Africa so
if you contact us at ask us
simplylearn.net we can give you some
insights into those questions as well
um
and Michael's question is about salary
ranges for cloud computing and I would
offer you
you can go to our course page it has
some of that information for you
um do you have any insights into
the kinds of salaries that the cloud
computing experts have so the salaries
depend on the roles right like uh Cloud
architect will probably have an average
salary of 110 uh whereas a cloud network
engineer would have 150k so it will be
somewhere uh 100 to 170 uh and then it
could be uh I would think it is at least
90k for certain rules but in general it
would be 100 to 150k Baseline salary
and that of course is uh the U.S
employees
um with that I'm going to go ahead and
ask one final poll
close out the event
find where that is
I'll start the poll
this is a pretty straightforward
question
this is uh how soon would you plan to
enroll if this is something that's of
interest to you and if
based on today's presentation think this
is something for you when do you feel
that you would want to do it again this
is
um
you know we always say that if it's
something that's going to improve your
life in your career
probably worth considering doing sooner
than later so
here's how people answered
about a quarter of folks are interested
in doing this immediately and maybe
taking advantage of the the discount
offer for that next cohort
um
about 40 percent within the next three
months
and we'd love to welcome you into the
University of Minnesota Learning
Community for the Carlson School
and with that
I want to thank
Matthew David for being here and helping
us through that
aspect of the presentation I want to
thank
me Ascent for being here and sharing
with us uh his knowledge as the
Carlson School director of the program
thank you samya thank you everyone thank
you Stuart
okay and I want to especially thank all
of the people here uh both on our
streaming audiences and our live WebEx
audience who attended today as I said I
hope we can welcome you into the simply
learned learning community and before I
go
I will put into the chat window one last
time
this email address asked us at
simplylearn.net along with the cloud
computing
camp
page link and
with that this concludes our live
preview so
have a great evening or have a great
morning everyone thank you
thank you thank you